there is chris ellis making his sixth
start of the year for the ordos he has
been a nice surprise for the orioles
first pitch swinging and calhoun sends
it right back up the middle for a base
hit
out to shortstop felika dives to his
feet throws to first picked out by mount
castle a nifty play calhoun gets down to
third but well done on both ends boy pat
belaka is steady now he is steady at
shortstop he can play second base
two balls two strikes and a breaking
ball drops in there for a called strike
three ellis picks up a k with a
curveball and works around a lead off
single stranding calhoun at the third
for jordan lyles 30 games overall this
will be his 29th start of the season 166
in the third innings he's given up 37
home runs over that time
lined and fair down the line
mckenna digging for second base and ryan
mckenna filling in for cedric mullins
tonight in that lead-off spot begins the
bottom of the first with a double here's
the pitch and the ground bull hit the
second should be two so lacked izzy and
on to first and easy double play
santander not running hard apparently
still favoring the leg and he is out to
end the inning speaking of tall guys dj
peters has got some length to him but he
doesn't like that breaking ball two
strikeouts now for ellis two different
breaking balls a slider and a curve ball
starts at just about belted but some
nice depth to it
3-2
inside ball four so there's another walk
for hernandez tavares who can run but
offensively he's been very inconsistent
here's the throw to first hernandez is
picked off mount castle runs to second
flips to the lake puts the tag on they
got him now the orioles had hernandez in
a stew that whole sequence ellis almost
picked him off twice and then he did
pick him off once and they're getting
his own
two
swung on and hit on the ground to third
fare backhanded by hernandez throws from
foul territory and mancini is safe the
throw pulled low off the bag to the left
he tried to slap the tag on him and trey
got in there to lead off the bottom of
the second long hold
the breaking ball grounded to third
hernandez to second for one this time
and on to first
we're not in time yeah this is going to
get reversed as long as lowe's foot is
on the bag so they're going over this
one at chelsea market in new york it was
a close play he was obviously out
one-two pitch grounded weekly the third
days charged by hernandez on the first
for the out and the sides retired no
runs a hit nobody left after two it's
nothing nothing
let off the end of the bat jones lunges
for it but he can't quite get it it's
just by his glove and out into right
field so travino able to shoot one
through over on the right side and the
rangers have their second hit
this pitch is hit to the right side
jones has it with the backhand to flip
this second for one on the first make
that two
a double play and chris ellis on one
pitch gets the twin killing and another
scoreless frame for chris ellis here in
the bottom half of the third the o2
grounded left side and in to left field
for a base hit past the dive of
hernandez and that's a leadoff single
for gutierrez he's starting to swing in
a little better this fourth into the
series he indeed is the one-two
chop to the left side deep in the hole
at shortstop kinder fluffy has it long
throw to first base too late
it's an infield base hit for mckenna and
the orioles threatening now with runners
on the corners on the play gutierrez
gets to third
hammers that ball out to center field
they're done hammered at all
the sinking liner and tavares will make
the throat of the plate and they got him
another double play
mount castle thought he had a sac fly
gutierrez didn't even slide and he's
gunned down at the plate by the strong
arm of leyote tavares to end the inning
the defense showing up again marcos de
plan making his 20th appearance in an
oriole uniform 23 and two thirds in his
pitch very good hits to innings pitch 18
punch outs 12 walks an opponent's
batting average of 212 against the
right-hander marcos dupont
as garcia chases that fastball
and goes down on strikes
[Music]
and he shoots this one left side that's
down the line fair ball
and it'll be extra bases for low he
pulls up at second base with a two out
double his 24th of the year
swinging a miss he gassed it by him and
the inning comes to an end deplon
strikes out dj peters and the ranger
strand two
[Applause]
off the end of the bat lyles will feed
it underhand to first in time to get
hayes that's out number one
and he hits this one in the air out to
right field
peters is there
and so is the ball two gone
and he lifts this one out to center
field tavares tracking it to his left
and that will win the enemy one out here
in the fifth inning de pons payoff and
that's high
all four and tavares and his good speed
are on base
this one back up the middle hits off the
plan's leg and he'll have no play
trevinho is on rangers have two base
runners now
fastball grounded to second base jones
fields it backhand flip to second
fellaika to first another double play
twice in three innings calhoun is
grounded into an inning ending 4-6-3
double play
two two
swing and a miss
and there's the strikeout of valeka
first strikeout tonight for lyle
got him on a fastball a one two three
inning jordan has retired seven in a row
his first two punch out five innings
complete it's nothing nothing crable is
the second pitcher out of brandon hyde's
bullpen tonight
the one-two fastball strike on the other
half and that's a strikeout kiner falefa
goes down looking
to the right side charging a few steps
as mount castle he plays it on a bounce
about shin high and walks to the bag and
a one two three six had him on the ropes
a little bit in the first inning
that's a fair ball
goes into foul territory shuffo digging
for two
the throw is not in time nick shuffo's
first orioles hit is a double this is
2-2 on the way to mount castle a swing
and a miss he got him two gone in the
sixth
one and two here's the pitch breaking
ball struck him out swinging lyles pumps
his fist so does trevino
as jordan escapes a tough jam here in
the sixth
good pitch from crable strikes out
peters on three pitches
strike three goal risky got him on a
splitter and another runner stranded in
scoring position
another 3-2
valenca hits it down the line it's a
fair ball it rolls into the corner
mancini is waved around third the relay
throw won't get there pet the bat comes
up with an rbi double and the orioles
with a one-nothing lead at the bat puts
a barrel on this one down the left-field
line and trey mancini is off and moving
from first base here he is pulling an
anchor around third base but he gets
there and he gets there with the lead
the earl's have a one nothing lead on a
pat valleca
one out
rbi double
[Applause]
in the air to right peters going back
and this one is gone
it's a two-run homer for gutierrez and a
three-run oriole seventh
come on calvin
where's kelvin been i'll tell you where
he's been he's been heating up in high
fives in the oriole dugout jose has two
of the four ranger hits
that ball powdered to left field it is
gone trevino with a home run
he's got a three for three night going
but he breaks
the scoreless run
rangers on the board 3-1 14 fastball
elevated
and probably above the strike zone but
look at jose going up and getting it
and here's lowe who was one for three
with a double
hit well center field long run out there
back to the wall it's gone
nathaniel lowe home run number 17 and
he's made it a one-run game in the ninth
the hot bat continues for nathaniel lowe
one-two
blooped
and caught pat filenka puts it away and
the orioles hang on for a 3-2 win over
the rangers tonight
you